what is your greatest advice for us
outside of our careers to fight for
happiness people do not fight for
happiness enough people have decided to
lean into cynicism and to blame and to
Envy into jealousy history media social
media pessimism like people are selling
all of you a bunch of [__] the world
has never been better the world has
never been better period this is the
greatest era to ever be alive I would
switch with all of you in 10 seconds and
unfortunately that's not what people
think so my advice to you is to fight
for happiness try to understand why I'm
telling you that go look at facts
instead of headlines that are built to
scare you a badass Bulldog I want to
know more is it a meme character and
then is Vayner Sports getting into U.S
soccer
the inner Sports has thought a lot about
getting into uh representing female
soccer players in the female soccer
league it's been
it's been a station
so that's that we have not talked as
much about MSL MLS excuse me we've but
we've talked about English Premier
League and going global so a lot of
conversation on proper football at
Vayner sports but I think
if I had a guest basketball is going to
happen before that so it could be three
four five years
um badass Bulldog you know truth is I'm
spending a lot of time right now on
character development you know I've
always
hot take I've had it skewed towards Meme
and like fun stuff but as the word
badass now is like more mundane like I
feel I can do a badass Bulldog toy for
six years old six-year-olds and it's not
like a bad word and so a lot a lot to
think through Bulldogs are incredibly
globally popular and so I want to be
very thoughtful with that character and
its development you know be friends for
me is my Pokemon my Sesame Street my
my Marvel my Star Wars and character
development is probably the most
precious part of all that and so given a
lot of thought and my question is what
is your walkout song Just Gonna know who
you are and if you thought of that
um yeah
the only one that I've ever really used
consistently for my Keynotes has been
first of the month by Bone Thugs and
Harmony
um
mainly because it's a song I once
listened to 853 times in a row
and it gets me pumped it also is like a
really kind of like rugged Hustle song
it's like so there's always just been a
very like from the dirt kind of part of
it plus I've always loved that like 93
of the world has no idea what the [__]
Bone Thugs-N-Harmony are saying in their
songs so it was felt like I was on an
inside like club and actually knowing it
so I would go with first of the month by
Bone Thugs and Harmony
honestly I love that but yeah man you
talk a lot about
um
being the guy that you wish you had as a
kid
um and
what would you say to yourself if you
were a resident right now like going
through the program just starting out at
Vayner
um from Ireland obviously you know I get
it I have a real real thought on this
because I know it's what I would do I
know myself
I couldn't recommend all of you becoming
friends with all of you more
we're going to teach you a fuckload I'm
gonna be who I am
but your relationships with each other
going through this is everything
all of you are going to be so far ahead
in the in the world of business and
marketing
because you're coming up Vayner at a
time where vayner's like apple in 1986
like you're on it you're at Facebook in
2010 you're like a Tesla 12 like
you know those are much bigger companies
than we will ever be but we are
disrupting and are historically correct
about advertising there are literally
people on this call right now who in 21
years are going to be the CMO of
Coca-Cola
literally
and so like what would I tell myself or
what would I be thinking that I need to
make sure that I get everyone's LinkedIn
Instagram Tick Tock email from this
group and go out of my way to be friends
with everybody on slack and create
common ground with them around
upbringing interests like at all costs
at all costs there's nothing more
valuable that will happen at Boehner
than you taking advantage of you guys
and gals are part of this little micro
crew
and that makes you connected in a
different way
and that all of you are coming into a
company that is going to accelerate your
opportunities whether within it
there are literally people in here that
are gonna be the bosses of people in
here and by being friends it's going to
be just a much more enjoyable life in
three years
there's also people here in 19 years
who again are going to be CMOS of the
biggest companies in the world that may
help your child get an internship at
that like this is it what is your
greatest advice for us outside of our
careers
to fight for happiness people do not
fight for happiness enough
people have decided to lean into
cynicism
into blame
into Envy into jealousy
people really like the world has done a
really good number on the world
mainstream media social media pessimism
like people are selling all of you a
bunch of [__] the world has never
been better
the world has never been better
period
this is the greatest era to ever be
alive I would switch with all of you in
10 seconds
and unfortunately that's not what people
think so my advice to you is to fight
for happiness
try to understand why I'm telling you
that go look at facts instead of
headlines that are built to scare you uh
as agen's year we kind of grew up with
the social media boom yep and uh we kind
of understand the consumer of mentality
and the social media first mentality yes
so my question is is how did you come up
with that before or like understand that
disruption before any of us understood
it
so one of the advantages of being older
is timing so when Myspace and even
before that Friendster came when I was
Myspace was very clear to me in 2005.
how old were you in 2005
six beautiful so when you were in
kindergarten
trying to desperately like figure out
what the world is
I was sitting in a liquor store
desperately trying to figure out like
why is the internet changing and what is
this and this feels different this is
different this is not
the last 10 years this has something to
it and
like look how cool like oh wait Rick
Ross and and Dane Cook the comedian and
Tila Tequila the model
um like they're winning on this thing
there's something happening and so I
took very big no and then very quickly
YouTube Twitter and Facebook came out
and I was like okay something's [__]
up and then right then and they are
right behind that the iPhone came out
and I was like okay this is a series of
things that make sense to me and
the radio used to be the most important
thing and then the television was
invented and the television only used to
have three channels and then I had 13
and then at 36 and then it had DirecTV
this makes sense to me and so I followed
my intuition
but and this is important for all of you
with AI VR nfts not only did I have
intuition I immersed myself in it
so I was 31.
30 when I made my first video
and I made a video
tasting wine because it's what I knew
um and so
I just put myself out there and made
sure I tasted it and was a practitioner
you can only learn by doing you can't
talk about it in theory and so you know
I think I have good consumer intuition
and I have good willingness to become a
practitioner and so it was obvious to me
because I was in it
you know
yep that totally makes sense and so like
all of you can read the emails going
back and forth at the company about Ai
and chat GPT and Jasper and mid Journey
or you could go and use it
right thank you so much thank you
um my question for you was what does
success look like for someone in a
junior position at Vayner well I think
success is very different money for all
of you
right like some of you were built in a
very Alpha home where like and very good
at school and type A and youth and you
you'll deem success as getting promoted
right getting the full gig and then
getting promoted like and I understand
that for other people success has some
sort of financial number in their mind
right some people here have like a
specific number in mind if I get to a
hundred thousand if I get to a 500 000
if I get to a million that's fine you
know for me
success is actually truly waking up on a
Monday morning and smiling with no
anxiety in your chest
and whether you make forty thousand
dollars or four billion dollars that
anything in between boy oh boy if more
people woke up on Monday morning smiling
cheek to cheek with lack of anxiety in
their chest
the world would be epic and that is the
framework that I'm trying to create
that's what this is that's why all of
you reacted the way you did when Claude
came on here you know like we're putting
a lot of effort into that and so we
won't get it perfect but we're trying
our hardest and so success for me is
whatever you want success to be
you know what I mean and and I'm there's
some of you sitting here right now that
want my job and very honestly
I'd like one of you to be the global CEO
of the Soul holding company because I
I'm getting old I need one of you to
rise up and take this throne and so
that's great and then there's other
people who've realized and can look
around the company and say whoa that
person looks happy and whoa they work
nine to five five days a week and have
time for their kids and everything like
I want that and that's beautiful and so
like or some of you are coming here to
like get as much knowledge as possible
and then you're gonna jump and start
your own vaynermedia and that makes me
happy for you too like I want success to
be your success but I want your success
to be your success not what I deem
success not what your mama deemed
success not whatever's cool on Tick Tock
team's success
like figure out what the [__] your
success is and be ready for it to change
what you get the [__] about at 22
changes at 27 and 31 and 39 and 52. so
you may have a success in your mind
right now and then you might scratch
that itch and you might realize I don't
like it that much
you know and don't be disappointed by
that because a lot of people get
depressed when they reach something they
no no be invigorated by that and realize
you're on to your next success
thank you you're welcome so my question
is you know obviously everything the the
Vayner kind of like family of companies
encompasses you know like the social
landscape the media landscape the ads
landscape they're all constantly
fluctuating constantly changing so you
know it can kind of be a lot sometimes
to like take it all in at once so my
question is how do you prevent yourself
from you know like getting burnt down
from it all what do you do to kind of
like keep the pace with all this stuff
I love myself
let me explain
I don't judge myself when I don't feel
like I've got it all grasped
you're absolutely right the shit's
moving super fast
it's okay to not be great at knowing how
Snapchat works it's right if you've
never downloaded Pinterest it's cool if
you have no [__] clue what the [__]
going on on LinkedIn
you just keep trying every day
I think the biggest reason I don't get
burnt out is because I don't beat myself
up
by far one of the biggest issues that so
many people have young old Left Right
black white is
people beat themselves up
and by the way do not get it twisted I'm
not talking about not holding yourself
up to a standard
but
it's just a little patience
back to the earlier question I've been
doing this every day for 17 years
good at it now
some of you have never thought about
these Platforms in this context prior to
when you started here
you're using it to hook up
you know so like you know I just have
empathy for yourself
right that's how you try you try and you
really like and I think you sense it
here like we have ambition we're
building a honey Empire but like
we're gonna give you a lot of time as
long as you're trying you know
what advice do you have uh for someone
who's about to turn 30 who has two young
kids and they're trying to like
exponentially grow their professional
career in this space
by realizing that patience is your only
Ally when it seems like it's your
biggest foe
gotcha right like the problem when
you're trying to do something fast
because of circumstances right imagine
right you're part of this residency
class 90 of your contemporaries or kids
right out of school that's a framework
where immediately you're like [__] I'm
so behind that all that whatever's going
through your mind the problem is when
you're trying to speed it up
like you trip
yeah the faster the you run the more
likely you're gonna trip
and so it's about the discipline of
understanding first of all I'm so pumped
you're in this program
I've had two or three people that I've
spoken to in the last six months who had
similar situations where they were quote
unquote a different age from the
majority of people in The Residency
class who 18 months later really were
like oh wait a minute I didn't have to
rush this was exactly right
um and uh you know patience is your ally
in this brother like the Merit of your
work is going to be the variable of your
success not how fast you politic it
it's awesome thank you you got it
brother how did you get to a point where
you can trust your creators to just say
Hey look
make what you want because I've worked
for teams in other media companies where
I had no Creator freedom I just do it
and shut up and just do it and what I
can appreciate is I can just kind of
give my passion in what is sports I
wanted to build a good company I'd
rather grown slower on something that I
knew would bring value to my employees
than grow faster with something that
sucks [__]
really hard to get people to wake up on
Monday morning smiling and having no
anxiety in their chest if everyone's
just making [__] with no say that's
[__] soulless and not fun
yeah yeah totally thank you appreciate
it you're welcome brother my question
for you is uh going back to Taylor is
that how do you wake up early in the
morning on a Monday and to stay hungry
you know
um I'm 27 and I'm trying to keep myself
going every day and I kind of struggle
sometimes so what is your take on that
what do you struggle with brother
I think just being motivated to get to
my angle you know what's your end goal
honestly six figures have a big house
I'm being a little materialistic but
well that's what that's why you're
struggling
yeah I mean I would have bet the I mean
you couldn't have walked into that more
that if I paid you to say what you just
said
you're literally the hypothesis I have
of why people are unhappy
you just made up an arbitrary goal for
yourself based on material things
without realizing the second you walk
into that home and you make six figures
nothing's changed
you know have someone be honest with me
you know so I'm I'm even better brother
I'm telling you from the deepest levels
of love that you can even imagine
I know you I've met a thousand of you
all of them have lost the second they
got there
you're you've got you've been able to
turn your perspective to something
that's very easy to turn your
perspective to the world is very good at
selling this
it's just super not true bro
I appreciate it thank you and kind of go
in adding to that like
like what like what should we do you
know or like yeah I mean I think I I the
alternative to that is
focusing on doing things you like I
wanted to say from the lemonade stand to
the winery
to now successful entrepreneurships both
serial successful entrepreneurships what
do you think is like a singular thread
that you pulled through from the
beginning that you still have now that
makes you that makes you successful
that I reverse engineer the person I'm
trying to sell something to
and I come from it from a place of good
intent like I really tried to make good
lemonade for 10 cents
like when people came to my dad's liquor
store and they wanted Santa Margarita
Pinot Grigio which used to sell for
12.99 and once I knew my [__] and knew
there was a better Pinot Grigio named
Chris
Kris peanut Regional for 7.99 I fought
like hell to get them to try it because
I knew they'd get a better bottle of
wine for five dollars less
Vayner is a success because we're trying
to get people to stop wasting money on
dumb marketing and spend it on good
marketing
when you have the customer's intention
in mind
everything you want selfishly will be
there in the end so I've spent like I'm
25 and I've had a little bit of work
experience and it could be research and
then I try to switch to strategic
Consulting then I switched to like
supply chain and then Farmhouse and now
I'm here thinking that this is what I
need and I think a lot of the reason
behind that is because I had it took me
like four or five years to accept that I
am someone who likes to put themselves
in a completely random situation every
two years
and that's
Foreigner X so my question to you is
like as someone who's just starting out
how do I moderate the line between
specializing in something right now
within vaynermedia and maybe going for
those opportunities later to explore
analytics brackets within the other
companies within the interacts uh would
I get that opportunity to kind of
explore that a little bit or get inside
in me I love that question look there's
there's it's very hard to answer that
question because there's so much
Serendipity that goes into that but the
fact that you can speak to this question
the way you just did as long as you're
over communicating with pet and all your
kind of like Champions that you interact
with the kalins
um you know whoever you work with on
these projects
um I think you'll find yourself in a
very good place what I'm most proud of
like we're not
bound to what I think most agencies and
companies are we're not rigid we're not
type A and so this is all about
communication and sometimes you should
stay and sometimes you shouldn't but not
me not you only God knows if that would
have worked out I think what you can't
be is crippled by the decisions you make
don't think that you're being Brash or
things of that nature or too fast you're
just following what feels right in your
stomach and maybe you'll do a couple
things at Boehner X and then the third
thing you're like wait a minute this is
it and you might do that for five years
and then five years in one day you're
like this is not it anymore and that's
fine too so I would just continue to
communicate
um take feedback balance that from
people who might say you're moving too
quick stay another year try this for
another six months make decisions live
in on those decisions and just keep
navigating
great thank you I guess like I feel like
from past experiences I feel like
there's slight negative connotation to
this like I've been badgered by
interviewers like why do you stretch all
the time tell them the truth
yeah tell them you're curious tell them
you're you're trying to find something
that will fulfill you I promise you you
don't want to work anywhere that use
that as a negative anyway
yeah exactly okay thank you so much I
have a funny feeling that wasn't a big
issue at Boehner
yeah definitely that's what that's what
makes me want to ask you this question
and it's a really difficult question to
ask to anyone else to be honest so yeah
I mean I think it's a very normal
um track for the curious
and haven't found that home yet I
noticed you know you have so much on
your plate as far as like all the hats
you wear with every company that you
started or or are a part of currently
what keeps you passionate to keep going
when you have so much going on only
asking because I don't have as much as
you but I have like organizations I'm
president of and I sometimes feel myself
kind of like not being passionate to
give my all to every role that I'm in so
I just wanted to know like what keeps
you passionate in every role
um accountability sometimes to do things
that you know I think one of the things
that the world is struggling with is
being able to deal with inconvenience
I think it's a real issue
I think it's a real opportunity we've
been
programmed parented
we've been fortunate
in a lot of ways in the macro obviously
many of us can grow up with difficult
situations but
we've demonized the capacity to be
inconvenienced
and when I make a commitment even though
I hate going to that meeting or I don't
want to do it
I've I've learned how to tolerate
short term or midterm inconvenience
that's number one number two
I'm also very comfortable similar to the
last question of changing my mind it's
okay to unwind a commitment
as long as you do it graciously you
could walk into the next meeting and say
hey
I need to I need to resign at the end of
this year from this committee I just
want to give everyone nine months now
you've created a light at the end of the
tunnel which almost weirdly makes you
even better those nine months you know
what I mean
you know I'd rather you be great on my
board for nine months or committee than
be below average for three years
um so I think it's a balance of willing
to deal with inconvenience and also
willing to graciously change your mind
both of those things keep me passionate
I know there's an out if I do it
graciously and appropriately
and I know that sometimes I have to
sleep in the bed that I made
thank you you're welcome
uh my question for you is you know
obviously being in this program just for
like what like a little over a month um
so far I've just been able to see that
like obviously there's a lot of like
love and care directed towards us and
directed towards teaching us and kind of
guiding us uh along our way and so my
question for you is just like frankly
like why do you why do you care so much
about like us and like younger people
and why do you guys see us as such an
investment uh going forward
I think it's the right thing to do
you know I think when you are blessed
there's a sense of responsibility and I
think
you know
so many of my business big big boy big
girlfriends
laugh at the concept of how much we put
in an upfront on this and how vulnerable
we are for people leaving and
I just don't see it that way I know you
know I think we have the best culture in
the world so I think a lot of people
will stay so that's good for the
business
but even if people didn't stay we can
afford to do it it's a nice thing to do
it leaves a positive impact on the
business world I want more people to be
affected by the way we see business
and I feel great that we get to show you
how it should be
you don't have a CL when I tell you the
greatest thing of this whole program for
all of you is knowing this exists
you know many people work for 25 years
and have no idea that you can do it
right
you know many of your parents and
friends and relatives and friends at
school and cousins think you're
completely full of [__] when you talk
about this company and that you're just
drinking from some weird Kool-Aid that I
made up
you know
um
it's
just the right [__] thing to do bro
you know it's awesome I love that yeah
appreciate it I believe yeah and it goes
back to the thing I said earlier Luke
which is like when you do the right
thing by the other side all the things
that you want will happen
I call it 5149 if I give all of you 51
of the value
then then 49 will be just fine by me and
I think too many companies try to get
somewhere between 80 and 100 of the
value
and once you figure out the model for 49
you're good you know
yeah that's great I appreciate that
thank you anyway I love you all
hope this was fruitful hope it helped
always available yeah thanks everyone
you're welcome
cheers everyone thank you thank you love
you
thank you that was [__] tight that
was [__] sick that was amazing best
meeting ever
no for real
I feel rejuvenated
I feel reassured it's good
okay me too
okay bye guys that's all
you know my favorite thing to do is make
pretend I leave to listen to what
actually is being said and I can tell
you right now that felt [__] amazing
I really did not log off because I was
like let me
let me I love you guys love you guys
have a great great day cheers bye-bye
everyone love you
foreign
[Music]